there was someone with $250,000 in
private student loan debts they started
at like 150 in only a few years they
went to $250,000 they're going to be a
million before she knows it so gives
these loans as an impressionable
teenager getting out of high school her
dad was like sign the loan I'll pay for
it her dad's ghosted her and is become
complete tear in the relationship did he
ghost because of the loan she wanted to
go to an instate School in California
that was public and save a lot of money
he was like go to Baylor that's where I
want you to go I will pay that has to be
one of the more daunting situations you
can see in her finances that she's given
up what would you recommend for somebody
like her you can't discharge student
loans and bankruptcy that's why they're
so terrible because they allow an
18-year-old kid to take on hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt regardless
of what they want to study and there's
no recourse you can't discharge that in
bankruptcy cuz you're getting an
education the education stays with you
so you just get screwed